Culture may feel exclusively human, but it's been
observed in all types of animals—
from chimpanzees to birds.
But what about the humble invertebrate?
Do fruit flies have culture?
Researchers tried to find out if fruit flies might have their
own cultural assets to pass down through the
generations, by looking at mating preferences.
They set up five rules to define whether a behavior was
learned and cultural.
First, the female fly must learn their mate selection
preference from watching other female flies choose
a mate.
For example, when an observer female watched a
second female select a green male to copulate with,
the observer females overwhelmingly chose a green
male when faced with their own mate selection.
Second, the learned behavior must be passed from older
to younger flies.
The observer female selected a green male regardless
of whether they saw copulating females that were older
or a similar age.
Third, the mating preference must persist.
After showing a female fly a green male copulating
every 15 to 30 minutes several times,
the observer female predominantly chose the green
male—even after 24 hours passed.
Since fruit flies only live for about 40 days,
24 hours is a significant slice of their life.
Fourth, the copying is based on a specific trait.
Even when faced with a green male that had another
prominent feature, like white eyes or curly wings,
the observer female still usually preferred them over pink males.
Lastly, the mating preference has to have
a repair mechanism.
In all the experiments, 80% or less of flies learned a
mate preference from observation.
Without a mechanism to correct for the 20% of flies
that didn't learn, the mate preference
should theoretically drop down to 51% by the
third generation.
However, researchers found that learned behaviors
persisted much longer during the experiment,
down to the eighth generation.
Researchers tested to see whether showing several
demonstrations of copulation would lead
to a higher percentage of learned mate preference.
When observer females saw equal proportions of
demonstrator females copulating with green and pink
males, the observer females had no mate preference.
In contrast, if all the demonstrator females were
copulating with green males, a hundred percent of
observer females went with the majority
and chose a green mate.
This exaggerated tendency in the flies to copy the majority
demonstrates the repair mechanism.
The scientists think their work could shed some light on
how social pressures produce local traditions.
These in turn might drive evolution as they
spread and are passed down in vast nations of humans
or tiny fly colonies in fruit bowls.